hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today i wanted to talk
about
the 2020 game awards nominees this video
is sponsored by expressvpn where we'll
hear a little bit from them
soon but i also did want to mention that
i've been on the voting jury
for the game awards for the last i think
five years total i'm not this year
thankfully that would be a real ethical
problem
but i can speak to you how that stuff
works a little bit um but of course
it is all on the website um people
always talk about like well but
but did jeff select these games i don't
understand
um no it is it is all done by all these
independent
um websites and i believe there are some
creators as well who are
on the uh on the boards but basically
all these people get to
nominate the games they think should
exist um and they also do the voting and
then
the public vote i believe if i'm if i'm
correct obviously you'd be better off
checking the website to go into me about
any of this because i'm not on the board
this year
i believe the public when you guys vote
uh
is 10 of the total weight so
yeah um let's go okay so naturally i
have seen
the game of the year category on the
internet
i look so tired today honestly
i keep seeing my own face i've done two
streams today i just look
anyway not the point here to talk about
video games so contenders for game of
the year are doom eternal
an interesting one a great game
a game i very much enjoyed and really
thought uh
was going to be my game of the year um
when i first played it and had even
first seen gameplay but i was obsessed
i really didn't like the platforming i'm
a person who who
is bad at platforming at the best of
times but i do usually enjoy it whereas
in doom and tunnel i just wasn't wasn't
into it i think i
ended up um liking doom 2016 more while
also really respecting what it did to
try to
make it so that it wasn't as repetitive
because doom 2016 is very much a game
where you walk through a hallway
you have a large battle in a large room
you walk through a hallway you have a
large battle in a laundry room kind of
rinse and repeat
doing the tunnel makes the mix that
formula up my favorite
doom is still the first one though so
anyway we're not going to
talk about all of these in that much
depth but that one is an interesting one
final fantasy vii remake
is very good is very good goes to
tsushima
fantastic game definitely in my top five
of the year
full disclosure i do work for s i e who
are listed here
um you know but still my genuine
opinions
you good luck paying for my opinions
anyone who's ever trying to do that it's
gonna have a hard time
hades ladies and gentlemen hades
i think haiti's his game of the year i
really do
super giant are incredible hades is the
perfection of
every formula they have introduced with
their already incredible game
i think it's hades here's my thing about
animal crossing
animal crossing also very good spent
more time in animal crossing than almost
any other game this year
had a great time you'll love to see it
awesome for us socially um
but also a terrible video game for bad
people
i do have a video on this channel that's
like vaguely along those lines
but like the online is terrible there
are so many like
just mechanics that make things way
harder than they should be
animal crossing would not get my vote
for game of the year despite
the significant impacts it would
probably still be in my top five but it
wouldn't win
the last of his part two i've spoken
about at length i think the last of us
part two
is likely to win i do think it's likely
to win
a very varied list is the is the main
thing these games are all very different
um i think the ones that i would have
included personally
i would have included half-life alex and
especially orion the will of the wisps
every time i was talking about ary i
have said i knew it would have trouble
um with award shows because it was so
buggy on launch
buggy's not even the right word it just
had performance problems it had um
really bad frame rate drops uh sometimes
i would get a black screen a game would
hard crash
they fixed them all though that game is
fantastic my games of the year are ori
and the will of the wisps
goes to tsushima hades and then maybe we
have animal crossing on the list i'm
sure there's other stuff that's come out
this year that i've already forgotten
about though because this year is too
big hello everyone
it's time to talk about expressvpn
this is a service i actually
legitimately do use and have been using
for quite some time i'm a big fan
sending data over an unencrypted
internet connection is like sending a
postcard
anyone could read it basically whenever
you're using an unencrypted internet
connection on
any of your devices everyone can kind of
see what you're doing even without your
authorization um even if you're using an
incognito mode your internet provider
can see all the sites you're visiting
and even sell that data to advertisers
expressvpn can basically give you more
security and also protect you from
hackers
and people who are trying to steal your
private information i personally have
used expressvpn to watch premier league
football
but there is now a service available
called peacock which if you aren't in
the us you could use expressvpn to get
access to
five dollars a month and you can watch
the premier league it's great it is
extremely easy to use um it is really
fast and i guess that's why they are the
top rated
vpn provider so find out how you can get
three months free by clicking the link
in the description box below
go to expressvpn.com alana best game
direction you say
that's where i think the final fantasy 7
remake is very good
that is a well directed video game just
a
incredible dedication to a vision
you know even in the changing of of the
original story
i also i'm glad to see half-life alex
there i mean these are all strong picks
for direction for sure
best narrative
oh i haven't played this thirteen
sentinels
i should look whatever this is up as a
person who likes video game storytelling
is it oh it's atlas 2d side scrolling
adventure huh
interesting i mean it looks cool
i mean that's that's the thing that i
really like about the game awards you
know
it is ridiculous to suggest that there
is a game of the year
in any year um that everyone should
adhere to right and that's the thing
that i think we all get really caught up
on is like arguing about what game of
the year is
because the title there there are every
outlet gives one
every outlet has a game of the year
every person has a game of the year and
they're all different there is no
definitive
video game of the year it just doesn't
work that way because people like
different things and it's a massive
credit to our medium that we have such
different stuff
but a show like the game awards does a
very good job of highlighting games that
people may not have heard of before
um and i wish we would see more variety
for that reason in some of the nominees
sometimes it did that for disco elysium
i feel like untitled goose game got a
lot of shouts there
but whatever this game is now on my
radar so that's cool best art direction
well it's there finally best art
direction i would go
one of these two probably goes to
tsushima
i've spent more time in a photo mode in
that game than any other game i've ever
played
best score and music for outstanding
music inclusive of score original song
and or licensed soundtrack
a lot of the same games huh really a lot
of the same games
i would go
do maternal for that one best audio
design
um
resident evil 3 is a good choice there
last of his part 2 was a very good
choice there that would probably win it
for me
best performance ashley johnson as ellie
laura bailey is abby
uh jin sakai hades
oh miles morales got a shot in there
that's cool
i'm surprised because not that many
people played it obviously because of
the release date
this one i think laura bailey wins it um
you know absolutely one of the best
actors of the entire medium
best ongoing i'm a fan of this category
i like that they started doing it more
uh see that's tough that's tough
no man's sky before the game came out i
was like i think it's gonna be bad
i think it's gonna be bad i'm not sold i
don't buy it
it kind of was on launch and then the
next update came out and it blew my mind
and then every update after that i now
love no man's sky and i've basically
been converted
based on the updates i also think that
fortnite gets [ __ ] because it's so
popular i don't think fortnite gets
enough credit for what it does as a
platform
the travis scott concert the the
trailers the
collaborations and crossovers that have
come as a result of
of um fortnite uh
it's it is incredible um not that it
hasn't won awards like this a million
times before but
i feel like everyone memes on it so hard
that sometimes we forget what epic has
done
and obviously the whole lawsuit thing
muddy stuff too but
very cool uh and and definitely
deserving of that nomination even though
people will make fun of it but
very subjective i'd go apex just because
i love apex
best indie of course hades is there
which is wild
best vr slash ar oh my gosh dreams
full disclosure i do work for sony
interactive entertainment right now but
dreams is amazing and i've been saying
that since 2015. go look on this channel
and you will find me talking about
dreams in 2015. um
certainly long before i started working
for so many interactive entertainment
innovation and accessibility well that's
gonna be the last of his part too so
we figured that out ladies and gentlemen
last of us part two
60 plus accessibility options more than
any other video game
ever made um but do want to give a
massive shout out to ub software being
nominated twice here
oops they've been doing such a good job
at forwarding their accessibility
efforts and that is definitely
worthy of recognition best action
i haven't played neo2 i know i should i
love that kind of game
derma tunnel this is such a wild
category so i've not played miles
morales yet i thought i might stream it
this week oops
so good to see jedi fallen order
nominated here because
like that should be in the sound design
one audio design i think they call it
amazing sound design for me this one
would be between these two
stupid webcam let me make myself smaller
there we go much better geez
yeah i'd be between one of the wisps and
um jedi fall in order
best role playing
well that's the easiest one of all time
that's going to be persona 5 real one of
the best video games ever made okay bye
best family huh all very good
nominations here
i have played all of these except
mario kart live home circuit crash
4 is really good crash bandicoot 4 is a
really good time that game is really fun
i have not finished it yet but i'm
pretty close i'm probably like three
quarters of the way through
my game is genuinely really fun
obviously animal crossing i don't know i
put like
400 hours in that stupid game it's
brilliant i guess what does this
category mean
just appropriate for family play i think
i would go with minecraft dungeons or
fall guys i think fall guys is probably
gonna win that one
best multiplayer
you see it feels weird that among us is
listed there because it didn't come out
this year
best multiplayer animal crossing
absolutely not because the multiplayer
in that game while it
it brings wonderful good times um
doesn't work very well
kind of sucks actually as a system no
content creator of the year oh my gosh
that's me
what it's so weird why i just don't know
why they picked that picture
for the record i'm speaking i'm
mid-speech here
this is a screenshot from the noclip
documentary that i worked on with uh
danny o'dwyer
and um i am mid-speech
so look at this beautiful picture
look how gorgeous she is stunning
next to this stupid [ __ ] idiot i have
known valkory for ages
i know of tim because of the fall guys
stuff
i'm less familiar with nick max and i
know a lot of what
jan does work wise i feel like i can't
have a say on this category really at
all because i don't
know these people well enough aside from
myself obviously
but i guess i have posted this all over
social media but it is
a point worth noting um done a lot of
charity work this year raised a lot of
money
um it might even be a million i haven't
i haven't tallied it all up across the
different
uh platforms like obviously i think
tiltifies around 500 000 but i've used
other platforms as well
the reason i was nominated for this um
is really because of everyone who's
donated to everything that i've done
uh to the people who tuned in to the
accessibility awards that i put together
um you know this feels like a nomination
as a result of my community being so
incredibly giving
um and open to me repeatedly doing
charity streams and asking for more
money um i think on average we've done
one a week
which is obviously a lot um sometimes i
feel bad about how often i ask but
it just feels like the right thing to do
especially this year trying to bring
some positivity people's way so
you know while we're on this particular
category um
i'm not gonna tell anyone to vote for me
i think my my likelihood of winning this
is so incredibly low and also
you know awards don't mean very much to
me it's not something i'm chasing but
the recognition is obviously awesome but
i mostly did just want to say thank you
like
to my community for helping me um
do a lot of good stuff this year don't
don't think i
should even be here but i do also
appreciate the judges
who did nominate me this year for
recognizing the
um like tremendous hard work i have put
in
and and that my community has joined me
on for some very long
tiring streams raising a lot of money
for a lot of different reasons so thank
you to everyone who has joined me on
those
okay moving on that's enough of that
boring nonsense best debut game
see phasmophobia i genuinely think this
game is underrated
in that like obviously it's very popular
and streamers are playing it
i just think mechanically phasmaphobia
is dope um but i have not played roki
this is gorgeous i did
check out a little bit of raji um
and had major performance problems with
that one sadly i have not played mortal
shell but based on that art it looks
like exactly the kind of thing that i
want to play and i love character
all right well we ended with a lot of
esports which is not my area of
expertise
uh which is why i don't work in esports
naturally i actually did cover
dota for a while in australia and i have
covered the overwatch league a little
bit
um in my professional career but
generally not much of a competitive
gamer personally but yeah that's pretty
much it just kind of like i don't know
if this is even interesting to anyone
just kind of
you know wanted to read over this at
some point and figured why not record it
a huge thanks to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video i will leave a
link in the description below to where
you can check out more
about expressvpn but otherwise that is
it for me today everyone i will see you
guys next time